no matter how long you've been playing
call of duty everyone can agree between
the player and the game it's always a
love-hate relationship things like the
current game just not feeling new or
innovative or a current patch that ruins
the game it's never one side or the
other it's always a mix
but the one area i've always found
consistent is campaign not every
campaign call duty has released has been
fantastic but even the ones that weren't
amazing still had some excellent moments
that pulled me back in enough to
complete the whole story
and cold war is no exception behind the
graphical issues in constant crashing
and multiplayer in zombies is a
masterpiece of a campaign but it's no
secret that not many people play it as
much as they should
only 20 of players on xbox have beaten
modern warfare 2019's campaign and i
doubt the numbers are different on any
other platform
this could be due to the marketing of
warzone being free and the trend of
battle royales but these numbers have
been consistent over the past couple
years with the growing push of
multiplayer and the addition of mastery
camos to both multiplayer and zombies
it's understandable why people just
don't play campaign as much anymore but
i think cold wars campaign can change
all of that
call of duty in the past has tried new
mechanics that are used one time for a
quick time event and never anywhere else
cold war does this but makes it relevant
throughout the whole game the new body
shield and takedown mechanic is used
constantly throughout the game as it's
both satisfying and beneficial to use
and the story is one of the best i've
seen in recent years and it takes me
back to the old black ops days
if i said to you what call of duty game
has a mind-bending twist
brutal or tough scenes as well as some
likeable characters with actual
personalities
your first choice may have been black
ops 1 you can also say the exact same
thing for cold war
black ops and even call of duty in
general always seem to have this running
theme of doing something bad to do
something good
like in modern warfare 2019 which was
capturing someone's wife and kid and
threatening to kill them in front of the
father
people like price in this case want to
do good but if they have to get their
hands dirty they'll do it
and that resonates really well within
cold war just in case there will be
heavy spoilers for the black ops cold
war campaign
so if you haven't beaten it i highly
recommend you play it first and then
come back the intro of the game sets up
the story which of course is the cold
war a period of tension between the
soviet union and the united states the
soviet union wanted to spread communism
throughout the world and the us clearly
didn't want that so they formed nato
to stop them which prompted the soviet
union to create the warsaw pact as a
result
black ops cold war not only uses a
historical event as the backdrop of the
campaign but also uses real life events
and programs that existed during the
time period during world war ii the
united states started researching and
developing nuclear weapons this was then
dubbed the manhattan project of course
as we know this would lead to the
creation of the fat man and little boy
nukes which destroyed hiroshima and
nagasaki during world war ii
the issue was that russia conducted
their own nuclear test and the design
was similar to america's own nukes which
led many within the cia to believe that
a russian spy had been feeding the
country intel on what the united states
was up to
this is where the conspiracy of perseus
started as this was the code name for
the hypothetical soviet spy within
america all of this was being
accompanied by some of the best mocap
work i've seen and it rivals modern
warfare 2019 for some of the best
looking cutscenes it's truly beautiful
looking
in and out of game black ops 1 has
always been known for its crazy
mind-blowing twist at the end of the
game
but even before things fell off you
never really felt content throughout the
game as you didn't understand the story
as something felt missing
you start the game being interviewed in
a chair with mysterious people watching
over you as you go through the missions
that constant thought of what's going on
and how is the game going to connect
this is constantly in your head
even reznoff was confusing as even
though you were separated at the prison
he always seems to show up next to you
especially when you're in the rat
tunnels when a nearby soldier asks you
you're talking to even though he's
clearly right next to him
all these events give off weird signals
with never any concrete ideas cold war
feels the exact same way
of course this starts out with perseus a
ghost of a man who apparently no one has
any info on besides one image from 20
years ago so already the idea of who
perseus is is constantly on your mind
and you may even start to suspect
someone in your squad is one of them
which makes it even worse as you're now
reading into everything they say
the first mission is more of a tutorial
to get used to the game and its new
mechanics like multiple dialogue choices
and the aforementioned body shields
it's after this where cold war changes
up the game and introduces character
customization and the safe house
the character customization isn't
anything expansive or innovative but
it's enough to feel like you're a part
of the action
as for the safe house this is a covert
operation so the location of this team
needs to be hidden and tucked away so
the safe houses where the meeting and
interaction takes place the safehouse
actually feels alive
not only can you interact with your team
and get to know them more but they do
activities and have conversations with
each other without your input some games
make areas feel more alive by adding
npcs but either don't add dialogue or
only have a trigger when the player
walks by with cold war it's possible you
spend so much time with one character in
their dialogue that you miss a
conversation with the other characters
and speaking of that interaction within
missions it's possible to hear different
lines than what other players heard
making the missions feel more unique and
worth playing again
good work don't think anyone saw you
follow me
that's your low profile belt god help us
all
follow me within the safe house is the
evidence board which is a small yet
fantastic touch as it makes the player
choose when to play the mission rather
than force them to cod sometimes can
feel like a story intertwined between
new missions that you just appear in but
cold war lets the player go to the
mission they want making it feel more
real as if you purposely selected this
mission the evidence board's design is
also a nice touch as every mission you
complete is another section of
information gathered all leading to
perseus gold war could simply have given
the player these missions back to back
without any reward for it but the
ability to not only select the mission
you want but look over the current and
past missions evidence makes it feel
like a real investigation
the safe house is also where these
doubts and suspicions come in every
character has certain dialogue options
that either give you vague answers or
just outright not give you an answer at
all
asking where we came from and why we
were selected for the team is a constant
dialogue option and it's confusing every
time as everyone in the safehouse is a
completely different and unrelated
reason this is where the suspicion of my
own team started for me as something
felt off i just couldn't figure out what
or why but all good investigations need
a starting point which is why the team
asks each other to remember their time
in vietnam when they first met perseus
this then enters a common theme with
black ops a vietnam mission it was an
overall good mission but afterwards is
where the game shows its newest form
cold war has two optional missions
within the game of course these are
optional and not required to complete
the story but
after looking into them it's much deeper
than a simple side mission
each one has a theme of finding a spy
and hunting them down you could simply
do these without looking too much into
them but that wouldn't show the true
reason for them being there in each
mission is other objectives
operation chaos is about decrypting a
floppy disk to not only take out the spy
but find the information on his
interspiring
operation red circus shows us the
potential suspects located within
america that need to be found and killed
all these give the player a puzzle to
solve but at the current moment we lack
the evidence to proceed as the evidence
to complete the side mission is found
within the future missions
much older call of duty titles used
intel or pickups as collectibles small
notes of information to give the story
but cold war eliminates these by adding
evidence the evidence can not only help
you gain more info about the current
mission but provide clues to complete
the side missions
one of the issues with intel is that it
was everywhere sometimes being three to
four on a level with it being placed in
such obscure spots that no one would
ever think to look there
evidence is placed within game areas the
player would encounter and rarely in
areas with combat so the player doesn't
get sidetracked by the gunfire to not
look around for the key evidence
and in sections where that is the case
there's always the icon at the top of
the screen letting you know you're in
the evidence area the game wants you to
find these not skip over them like it's
intel as the evidence is crucial to a
full game experience not finding any
intel throughout modern warfare
2 isn't going to lose you much story not
finding evidence in cold war can lead to
not being able to complete an entire
mission the mission brick in the wall is
an early showcase of the effective way
how all of these coexist together you're
sent on an investigation to find a man
named volkov you meet an agent whose
name is greta who provides you with
information of not only a man named
kraus but another agent of hers who was
captured this
is the optional objective of the mission
should the player choose to do this
they'll be given the choice of killing
or releasing the agent as well as
collecting the evidence for one of the
side missions in the future
the choice of letting him go or killing
him affects the future as it's
discovered he was planning on betraying
his current organization which is why he
shows up at the interrogation scene
while being interrogated the player is
given multiple options here too
should you cooperate nothing happens
other than scripted events but should
the player mouth off it can lead to
greta's death once you're saved you then
chase volkov to the end of the warehouse
where you're given the killer capture
order none of these options affect the
ending or the overall path of the game
but each option gives different dialogue
and reactions to your choice
that's three choices within one mission
which means there are many combinations
given to the player
some players may have saved greta and
her agent but killed volkov others may
have done
vice versa which makes the playthrough
more unique and fun to experience but
the true form of choice is easily shown
in desperate measures
desperate measures is easily one of the
best missions in the game you start out
as a man named belakov who was a mole
within the kgb
tasked with getting a bunker key so he
can let adler and bella inside
the only issue is one person has that
key general charkov the game gives you
five
options to tackle this all with their
unique challenges poisoning charkoff
seems easy enough but not only is the
poison locked behind a cabinet chargoff
also grabs the wrong cup meaning you
need to distract them in order to switch
them
alternatively you can reprogram a new
key yourself but the guard won't let you
pass without some convincing the level
provides you with a map and science
you're never lost and know exactly where
you are and where you need to go
even allowing you to mark sections on
the map so there's a waypoint and giving
you the opportunity to explore the other
possible
options should you want to the game even
provides an optional objective to kill
the man who wronged you just missions
ago which is a nice touch
while it seems easy at face value every
named location in the headquarters is
restricted thanks to the recent security
measures so not only are the guards on
high alert you aren't allowed to be
inside these areas either so you have to
lock pick your way through all the doors
and stash the bodies
once completing desperate measures the
players should have enough to finish
those side missions
operating chaos and red circus as we
discussed are the side missions that can
be completed right away but
it's intended for the player to solve
the puzzles to proceed with the mission
operating chaos has the floppy disk and
red circus has the finding of the
suspects these missions won't be solved
by everyone but it doesn't take a
scientist to figure these out
treyarch knew these would be tough so
they actually made multiple versions of
each of the missions so players couldn't
just look up the answers online
but instead have to look up how to solve
it and do it themselves preventing the
easy way out
doing it yourself is much more enjoyable
and rewarding it takes more thinking
than normal to figure it out
but it took me around 15 minutes to
crack each one treyarch handled these
very well giving the player a challenge
that may require minor note taking and
brain power but not too much thinking as
it would cause too many players to
stress out and
not do the mission considering it's
optional so it's not going to hurt their
story experience
the missions you embark on afterward
aren't anything special but the set
pieces for these are fantastic looking
going from a motel in the middle of the
desert to a base on top of a snowy
mountain was incredible
while most of the credit for these
missions is going to be down to the
actual puzzles involved in the side
missions the locations that they take
place in are still breathtaking to look
at and this goes for all the missions as
well walking through the woods only to
find a giant base housing russian
soldiers is extremely intimidating this
game has so many breathtaking locations
it's hard to forget what you were doing
sometimes you were just taking in the
scenery cold war at this point in time
takes the final page of black ops 1's
book and it's the twist of an ending
this whole time something has felt off
not enough to worry the player too much
but
not little enough to brush it aside is
just overthinking to start we need to go
through end of the line
perseus has supposedly reverse
engineered the code so not only can he
still detonate the nuke he has but all
the others as well
the ending of this mission comes as a
shock as you're hit by an rpg and only
able to save one person you and the
person you save become wounded and
you're so badly hurt that you need more
than just simple bandages in first aid
now i've never been hit by a shrapnel
but i don't think i syringed through my
eye socket and into my brain is the
correct way to go about this
once this happens though we go through
one of the weirdest missions in the game
we're back in vietnam being voiced over
by adler
he explains to us what we told him in
our report in vietnam and we act it out
in game but nothing is at all making
sense as when we disobey adler he
changes up the script and mentions going
to different scenarios
every time one scene is completed we see
glimpses of past events from our
memories before we're shot back into the
next scene
one is during the day then it's at night
then adler's the model for the enemies
then time is slowed down then there's
zombies then the laboratory is falling
apart nothing makes any sense that is
until the end of the mission when we're
told that we aren't who we think we are
we aren't cia
agent bell we're a russian soldier who
worked for perseus
back in the first mission we see arash
cap two people in the truck
we were one of those two people except
we lived and adler captured us and took
us under a program called mk-ultra which
was a real program used by america which
was a form of interrogation through
drugging and mind control which is
exactly what's happening to us we were
being brainwashed just like mason was
back in black ops one
and this whole time we thought we were
helping catch perseus but we were
actually being used for information
everything was fabricated our name
relationships and the entire document at
the beginning that we created
was faked we thought we created our own
soldier not knowing that this was a fake
report to get us to believe that we were
the ones who created those pages when in
fact we were something completely
different
this is not only a shock to bell but the
player as well the fact that throughout
this whole campaign
we are being lied to and used for for
their own gain is shocking to hear
which brings us back to that classic cod
theme of doing something bad to do
something good
adler in this case is like captain price
they want to do good but if they have to
get their hands dirty they'll do it
where captain price kidnapped someone's
family to get answers
adler drugged a russian soldier to force
out information adler used his own
memories of vietnam but twisted them
like they were ours so we can remember
that lifelong bond between the two of us
which makes it easier to trust him it
was then after that bombshell of
information we were given the choice to
choose
truth or lie i legitimately had to pause
just to think as there were so many
variables in play
yes we did get drugged but perseus is
killing innocent people so maybe tell
the truth but
belle was russian so his allegiance
should stay with russia so
lie constantly replaying these ideas in
my head as to what would make the most
sense in the scenario
the first option i chose though was the
truth i assume that after this was done
we would eventually save europe and then
hopefully i'd be able to portray adler
at the end of the game you can imagine
my surprise when i was almost 100
correct until the screen went black not
knowing if i died or not the ending made
me feel empty
not knowing who died or lived and
knowing that adler was going to betray
me anyway
even after i helped him despite what he
did to me when games have multiple
options most of the time you replay the
ending just to see both options
this wasn't the case i rebooted up the
mission not only just to see the other
option but
hoping this one gave me a satisfying
conclusion the issue was is i didn't
know what was going to happen if i told
the lie i assumed i wasn't going to
leave the room alive but you
not only were able to live but set up an
ambush which created one of the most
captivating endings in call of duty to
date once you meet at dugo you ambush
them and the final objective
eliminate your former team appears
that's absolutely gut wrenching
at any point in time you could have shot
your team but it's always a game over
screen this is the one time in call of
duty that you can shoot your own team
with no repercussions so it was a very
different feeling
it definitely felt crazy that i was even
able to kill mason and woods in the
first place two guys who have not only
been a large part of this current game
but the other previous releases and it
was definitely a roth mission
the mission while not great for obvious
emotional reasons is probably the most
satisfying ending the game has
with no cliffhangers or cuts to black
it's a pure ending with a conclusion and
personally to me is the better option of
the two
and i'm not afraid to admit that and it
seems like a lot of the community agrees
too
black ops 2 like cold war has multiple
endings and just like those two the
endings can either be good or bad
depending on your choice
each had their own way of going about it
with black ops 2 they had multiple
factors that contributed to the ending
but it was all cutscenes cold war's last
choice was the main driving factor for
what happens at the epilogue except you
actually got to do the bad ending and
not just watch it in a cutscene
it feels more rewarding actually being
able to do it yourself instead of
watching it all unfold which is what
treyarch was going for
with things like multiple choices brutal
cutscenes and mind-bending twists it's
hard not to see the similarities between
cold war and the previous black ops
games and it feels nostalgic to be able
to play a campaign with the style of
those games with all the new
enhancements and mechanics that came
with cold war which is why this campaign
is truly one of the best campaigns
that's been released for cod in recent
years
thank you all for joining me on this
journey through black ops cold war how
did you like the campaign and what
ending was your personal favorite any
and all thoughts and comments leave them
down below with that though take care
and i'll see you in another video
[Music]
goodbye
you